what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another character breakdown
video I'm here with gray area and today
we're gonna finish our predictions for
Melisandre in part 1 we talked about why
we thought Melisandre was going to
volantis and what that might mean for
the upcoming war what the night King at
the end of the first video gray area
asked me a very interesting question so
I want to pick up right where we left
off shall we begin
Melisandre is like a magical being
she's hundreds of years old so can she
even become a white that is a very good
question and I'm not even sure if I can
answer that I would probably need to
think about that for a while but I would
like to think Melisandre can not turn
into a white if she did bring over the
fiery hand from volantis they might be
able to turn into White's because
they're not as powerful as Melisandre
but I think since Melisandre has such a
strong connection to the flames she
might not be able to I really don't know
though but speaking of Melisandre dying
I did want to ask you a question how do
you think Melisandre will die
Melisandre said she was coming back to
Westeros where she would ultimately die
so I pretty much take that as a
confirmation we will see that happen but
how do you think that happens do you
think Jon will kill her if she returns
to the north do you think Davos will
kill her for killing princess Shireen do
you think Arya will do it since they are
supposed to meet again or do you think
she will die by one of the dragons
because Melisandre has always said death
by fire is the purest death
you took the quote right out of my mouth
death by fire is the purest death and I
think like there's no other way for a
fire priestess to die then by fire and
for her to be killed by ice would
probably be torment from Melisandre
there's also the question like is
Melisandre already dead Melisandre
drinks Strangler and she doesn't die
yeah that's crazy she might be a little
invincible right now fire might be the
only way you can kill her right what is
that saying if you live by the sword you
die by the sword if fire is what keeps
her alive than fires what will kill her
but you know in the books she doesn't
eat like she goes days without eating
she has
to remind herself to eat she has to have
a fire burning at all times around her
it can never go out so I wonder if those
fires that need to be burning I don't
like if those fires go out then that's
probably it for Melisandre doesn't
Melisandre also hope that eventually she
won't ever need to sleep again yeah in
her dance of dragons POV chapter like
she doesn't really sleep exactly but I
do vaguely remember her either saying or
thinking to herself that hopefully she
gets to the point to where she never
needs to sleep again I do know that she
sits up all night like by the fire
trying to see visions and stuff in the
flames so she's like trying to transform
into this other worldly beings she's
definitely way more magical than she is
human Melisandre is so interesting like
I can't wait to learn more about her
because I think there is a lot of
potential for her character yeah like
her I did some digging on her like not
too long ago and what from what I found
she's a child of the forest she's not
from a shy she's she's a child of the
forest she has red eyes the only
characters in our stories that have red
eyes are ghosts
drogon they're animals but the ghost of
high heart and blood Raven do you think
that's why our powers are stronger at
the wall exactly and she has this vision
in her POV chapter where she's seeing
hardhome right uh-huh
but years ago like many many many years
ago like this incident happened at
hardhome and we know that slavers were
taking people from hardhome and like
taking them over to Essos and selling
them into slavery
so Melisandre says that she comes from a
shy no children in a shy and then she
said she was sold as a slave to the red
temple but the slaves at the red temple
has fire tattooed on them
more Kouros covered in flames but she's
not now that she say that I actually do
remember you bringing that up to me so
you think she may have lived at hardhome
and she was taken as a slave when she
was a little kid and she doesn't
remember it happening but she is seeing
those visions and the flames what
happened to her village
yes she's she's seeing like she's seeing
dual things at one times because she's
seeing hardhome but she hears Melanie
lot seven so it sounds like she's
hearing like a slave auction and she was
in Lot seven but she's seeing hardhome
now was bloodraven north of the wall
when that happened at hardhome
no I think that was before bloody way
before that right right yeah because
there is a popular theory that
Melisandre is his daughter that's
exactly what I was thinking because if
he was north of the wall when that
happened then that would lend to the
theory that bloodraven is Melisandre his
father but the timeline doesn't add up
because Melisandre is a few hundred
years old isn't she yeah she's older
than him yeah and he wasn't up there
that long ago but um the eyes his eyes
are red because he's a green seer the
three-eyed Raven or Brendan rivers tells
bran that that's how the gods marked the
children of the forest there they're
born with golden eyes but if their eyes
are green or red that's how he marks
those that he chose to give to give his
gifts to that's right Noren summers eyes
golden brains direwolf yep some lady
gray wind and I marry I have gold eyes
shaggy-dog has green eyes and ghost has
red eyes absolutely and when he said
they had golden eyes I immediately
remembered bran talking about summers
eyes in the first book I think and he's
thinking about how golden they look yep
there's just so much interesting [ __ ]
going on up there north of the wall the
books are freaking awesome the show is
freaking awesome like it's crazy that
Melisandre isn't really a primary
character and she's so interesting it's
a shame the television show couldn't
dive into her character some more if
they would have made this show 10
seasons long they could have really
flushed out Melisandre character
it sucks that we only got two quick
scenes with Melisandre in season 7 I
just hope she doesn't die during the
same scene or same episode when she gets
back from volantis I really hope it's
not gonna be like that I feel like the
first three episodes we're gonna deal
with the White Walkers the next we're
gonna be dealing in a lot of politics
and who's gonna be on the throne if
there's a throne left who's going what
way like it's gonna be a lot of that I
agree it probably will play out like
that but I want to get back to what we
were talking about earlier
Melisandre says death by fire is the
purest death if Melisandre would happen
to die by fire how do you think that
would happen do you think it could be
one of the Dragons either Daenerys has
dragons or even the night Kings dragon
or do you think she will sacrifice
herself in some way with the use of fire
being that she is magic I resonate
Melisandre with magic I think that she
can only die by dragon fire or wildfire
wildfire is made through magic and
Dragons are magic so it would have to be
one of those two do you think that would
be a Daenerys burning her or would it be
the night king burning her with the
dragon I don't think it would be
Daenerys she hasn't done anything she
would have to do something to Daenerys
and she hasn't done anything to Daenerys
yet that's exactly what I've been trying
to figure out what can Melisandre
possibly do now that would cause her
death even though Melisandre did say
death by fire is the purest death I
could still see her dying by the sword
well maybe she's Nissa Nissa yup I've
thought about that too and I even made a
video about Melisandre being nice Aneesa
because she is the one who believes in
that prophecy or legend the most she
even put on a fake ceremony for staying
as just to pump up his head that was
when we saw Stannis pull the burning
sword out of the statues chest on
Dragonstone in season two I think but I
have been thinking maybe this whole time
Melisandre is actually the one who is
meant to bare her breasts and have a
sword plunged into it she already has
the fire burning within her so maybe if
Jon or some what did plunge a sword into
her heart it would combine with her soul
in whatever magic she is made up of the
Lightbringer
the forging of Lightbringer says when he
stabbed her or her courage and strength
went into his lead so Melisandre is
courageous she is she is strong she I
mean who else I couldn't go into like
you take a hard man like Stannis and
just go in there and run his whole whole
life like she just took over but the
only wrench in it is that John doesn't
really love her yeah that's the only
problem I have with that theory
Nissa Nissa was his wife and obviously
Melisandre is not John's wife unless the
word wife is a loose term that can be
interpreted in another way but I don't
know about that I know a way she could
die what's that we haven't talked about
it yet you're on you're on could kill
her really how so in the books in the
Forsaken check he's like taking priests
and stuff and he's doing doing things
with them like he's he's he has Pyat
pree like one of the warlocks yeah Epton
like i don't know he's trying to do
something so he's collecting like
priests so he could take her and we know
that in the books Victarion which isn't
in the show has a red priest with him
so maybe Iran gets a red priest with him
and maybe it's Melisandre and maybe
she's there to be counterproductive to
his cause and help John that would be
pretty interesting I think if you look
at most likely ways gonna die
she's been foreshadow it's like
foreshadowed in the show that she's like
the sacrifice Queen like she sacrifices
people in the show she thinks it's an
honor to her gods um she thinks fire is
the purest death so I think it's most
likely that she dies by fire by
sacrificing herself I agree that makes
the most sense to me she has sacrificed
so many people herself but now it may be
time for Melisandre to do the ultimate
sacrifice by giving her own life to
ensure the night king is defeated she
said she was coming back to Westeros one
last time and she also said she was
going to die
I don't think they would have shown us
of that scene unless it would happen it
would make her story and on a really
high note alright folks that is the end
of our Melisandre predictions for season
8
I want to thank gray area for joining me
and I also want to thank everyone who
stopped by to watch the video if you
would like to see more videos from me in
gray area then you can head over to her
channel where she just released our
video about Arya Stark I will put the
link to her channel down in the
description of this video I highly
recommend checking that one out and many
of her other videos before I go I have
to thank all my supporters on patreon
and also I will be announcing the name
of the next winner of my Game of Thrones
Season 7 blu-ray giveaway in the next
video I hope everyone has a great day
I'll see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]